you're watching screen junkie central
today's episode is brought to you by
t-mobile
the uncarrier what's going on everybody
Dan roll come to you from comic-con 2016
the Sun is setting on day 3 but Hall age
is heating up because Marvel just
dropped some huge information the fans
are filing out we found out so much our
first look at spider-man homecoming at
thor ragnarok casting news on black
panther a new Doctor Strange trailer
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 footage
Kurt Russell as star Lords father brie
Larson is Captain Marvel so much to talk
about I'm going to talk to some fans
Hector Navarro is going to talk to some
of the Marvel stars themselves let's get
going the Marvel panel just stood out
you were in there what was the standout
for you what was the biggest piece of
news that came out just now the Black
Panther cast coming out Michael B Jordan
Lupita Nyong'o chadwick boseman and a
latest cast member
Danai gurira it's as they've been saying
on Twitter Black Panther soul it that's
true
we knew that Michael B Jordan is in the
movie we did not know that he was going
to be playing kill monger the villain
Chad was a buddy of mine so when I when
I went as a fan so when I saw Civil War
I was blown away I feel like he you know
is definitely soul stole a lot of scenes
that he was in if not all of them and
I'm in it and it got me that much more
excited about being a part of this this
cast is the next big thing I mean
anybody who watched Creed knows this guy
this guy's an ally I can't even I don't
can't form words at this point at Danai
gurira
a big surprise from The Walking Dead now
part of the cast of Black Panther in
fact when she came out I completely lost
my mind I'm super jazzed about seeing
this cast assembled I love Lupita I'm
looking forward to kicking ass like
really looking forward to that I'm
looking forward to bringing or conduct
in life and populating it and you know
you read about it in the comic books and
obviously there's illustrations of the
place but to have the expanse that a
film can give what Conda I think is is
going to be really cool I think there's
going to be some cool technological
things going on
and it's going to be epic I think
especially with Ryan leading the charge
and the truth of the matter is man you
know people want to see human stories
you know say if you give them something
if you give them something human you get
the opportunity repetition in different
flavors you know humanity cuz you know
cut through in most cases you know so
let's say sighting time and whenever I
see the kids just not badly managed its
heart is it's heartwarming man it's also
terrifying because you want you don't
wanna disappoint those kids but it was a
bad movie you know say that single shot
of him in Creede were that the boxing
scene where you just see one shot it
looks like one take I cannot wait to see
what he does in Wakanda and be back with
Michael B Jordan what Conda as it's
written in the comics they are an
anomaly because they are completely
politically independent from the rest of
the world so for me that is a really
good place to start some drama some
group global drama the other thing that
people didn't necessarily know where we
were going to get we actually got kind
of an extensive look at spider-man
homecoming they have the movie shooting
for less than two weeks but we got our
first look at some of the footage from
the film what'd you think of the
presentation they made how they're
framing that film very much kind of a
high school coming-of-age movie yeah it
just felt like a high school a very
straight up high school movie they take
us through Peter Parker's day at school
they have some great music playing and
he's got him in his in classrooms he's
checking out girls he's just yeah it
feels very John Hughes inspired very
sweet and then right at the end you see
vulture kind of coming down so it's like
yeah this is a high school movie but
it's gonna be a Venice high school movie
and so yeah I mean I really really love
the Spider Man stuff Mean Girls
spider-man that is oh my gosh it's
something that we don't ever see that we
haven't seen before from a spider-man
movie like actual high school drama
that's that's I think it's going to be
amazing
seriously though quick question spill
the dirt Tom how much of a diva is he be
real tom is the nicest person in the
world he's staring at me from across
over there and I can't say anything more
movie fight things ever if I can be on
movie fight I love you guys
oh that's going to happen absolutely
absolutely do you know so much happen in
this panel that we almost forgot to talk
about Thor Ragnarok and the footage the
screen from that and the fact that
clearly Thor and the Hulk are battling
on Planet Hulk he was just going crazy
about so uh I mean I have a choice yes
yes savage savage Hulk I mean it's
something that nobody ever thought we'd
ever see cuz when Planet Hulk really
wasn't gonna be a thing but the sielmann
the I like the sketches of him in the
armor
oh my god I saw them kind of charging at
each other in an arena and at the end
Hulk is like has armor on he's going to
fight in some crazy devil looking beast
I don't even know what that was but you
know what proceeded it was something
really funny it was like a mockumentary
about what happened with Thor during
civil war and it felt like like the
office sort of that showed you like Tyco
ATT's humor oh but then mixed with the
action but yes it was just hilarious the
little teaser that they did that to show
like what they were doing during the
whole Civil War as a kind of promo
before the whole Ragnarok and I'm
telling you I just even know to know
that they're just starting like a five
five days into filming it I'm so excited
to see what they do with that the cast
sounds amazing that they're putting
together and stuff not too sure it's
gonna have with Natalie yet though they
didn't mention her they didn't mention
no mention we don't know where Jane
Foster is exactly not right now not yet
everything the biggest piece of news is
what we all suspected which is that Kurt
Russell is in fact playing star-lords
dad but not only that not only that he's
eager yeah what ego like how how is it
even possible he's a living planet
how and not only is he a living planet
he's played by Kurt Russell and oh by
the way he's Peter Quill's father yes
and he Welker Russell's also living
planet that's what I've heard at least
that's true it's really about taking
these characters some of whom are great
characters on the page some of them are
goofy on the page but trying to put them
into a movie and create them with real
heart real warmth and real reality
that's what I try to do with rocket and
I think it's the same thing I'm trying
to do with ego in this movie and that's
the center of the movie in the same way
rocket is the center of the first home I
wouldn't expect them to just be like
father and son I think there's going to
be a twist there I wonder if at the end
they're antagonists I don't know but
yeah it's going to be really cool and
Kurt Russell was on stage and everybody
loved that - yeah first of all if you're
worried about the tone being different I
don't know why you would it had exactly
the same tone as guarding the galaxy the
humor was there
yondu you can tell he's doubling down on
Rooker yondu had some badass stuff going
on if you love Groot already baby Groot
may be the most adorable thing I've ever
seen in my life and then they showed a
teaser trailer for guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 that just brought the house
down I mean they had all the ravages in
costume you know they really put on a
performance oh my god I love the obscure
Marvel characters I mean listen I'm a
Marvel mega fan
I loved Marvel since I was a little kid
so to be able to put a character like
taser face is a really goofy character
in guardians the galaxy is like a joy to
man and probably at least fifteen or
sixteen other people out there in the
world I don't think I need to tell you
who they are fans of Doctor Strange we
saw some great Doctor Strange stuff the
doctor himself edited Cumberbatch on
stage and a new trailer what did you
guys think of the new stuff we saw from
Doctor Strange today Benedict
Cumberbatch was the perfect casting I
mean from the few moments that we saw on
in the in Hall H I was convinced that it
was Stephen strange in fact we're big
fans of the comics and always you know
with comic fans you have high
expectations for the movies and I'd say
what Marvel had in just that you know
couple of minutes
surpass like what I could actually
conceive strange is the the arrogant
neurosurgeon that just wants to heal his
own hands everyone's on their our agenda
is just to gather the disciples and get
ready for when these darker forces to
protect themselves from their outside
darker forces yeah is there anything new
that you learned what we saw today
something you didn't know about the
movie that you're taking away from the
new things that we saw in the hall today
I mean I think the the visual effects of
it were just totally blew my mind we had
a lot of wire stuff which is not simple
wires but we're you know when you're
tangling in different ways that you have
to make sure your articles around and
down here when you jump and land and
then spin the other way the next time
and which was kind of risky if you did
it wrong that was tricky but we nailed
it I kept asking Scott I mean so sighs
there any fighting and he was pitching
the story yeah yeah that mess is flying
kung fu and I was like I'm in let's go
big Kung Fu fat giant I wanted to be
Bruce Lee when I was a kid you know they
really take you to the astral plane you
really get to see you know we've seen
superheroes use technology and might and
stuff like that but how does magic play
into that you really get to see that in
the trailer you know I just popped my
comic-con cherry and watching it with
11,000 fans and it was just like wow
they're stunning oh by the way brie
Larson is Captain Marvel yes now she was
rumored to be Captain Marvel we were
pretty sure that it was her but they
confirmed it today she came out she got
a little picture she took a little
picture outside with a hat that I have
now retweeted I'm very excited about
this casting she's a tremendous actress
if you haven't seen room see it that
announcement came out with the entire
Marvel panel on stage I think the place
freaked out that was probably the
loudest that I heard Hall H free license
in the last five years went from you
know one small film to an oscar-winning
in less than five years now she's on the
biggest stage Marvel they're gonna make
their lovely Captain Marvel people
wanted to see a Marvel lead and a female
role she's the one they didn't really
like make a big deal out it's like oh
it's brie Larson me but like we're split
yeah
we are very split yeah you know she's an
incredible actress I love her to death I
just not seen it yet okay and I think
that she's gonna be just fine I mean I
the character of Carol Danvers is a
really really awesome complex character
that I think that she can pull off
because she has that like you the
connection with audiences from 21 Jump
Street to room I mean she's really good
all right everybody that's it from here
at San Diego comic-con 2016 it's almost
dark out here but the internet is
lighting up so much stuff happened today
thank you so much for watching I hope
you enjoyed everything Warner DC Justice
League Marvel everything that broke
today we will always be covering it for
you right here at screen junkies in the
days and the weeks in the months to come
thank you so much for watching from
comic-con here in San Diego California
I'm Dan Moreau for howl Rudnick's saying
bye-bye
thanks again to sponsor t-mobile with
double the LTE coverage get your screen
junkies fix and more places to watch our
previous show click to the left and to
view everything else from screen junkie
central click to the right